[Music]
hey let's see how New York's doing what
do you say
have you ever eaten the spam never ever
say spam is it good I mean I ate it okay
honestly I kind of like her the most so
far
as a child I don't think so I always see
it in the supermarket I saw it yesterday
in a supermarket by the way was it
locked up because did you hear about
this now no that spam was that like that
cheap kind of food that we all had in
college
times have changed apparently uh the
canned meat which sells for 3.99 what's
pricey is getting locked up at least in
one drug drugstore Dwayne Reed in the
Port Authority the bus depot there uh it
says it's stocking spam and plastic
anti-theft cases according to the New
York Post Walgreens which owns Duane
Reade would not say why it's securing
spam at this location many stores in
this
why is this news City have started
locking up everything from toothpaste to
deodorant because of
theft I mean a rib eye
yeah for right now okay let me explain
through what you guys are all laughing I
know this is really funny to you guys
and you think it's hilarious go spam
locked up
um when you start having people that are
not going into places and stealing like
for like Electronics
hair and beauty stuff see if you can
resell and Gucci [ __ ] when you have
people going in there and stealing food
the cheapest amount the cheapest kind of
food stealing food that I wouldn't eat
if I were starving your problem is
bigger than oh man people are stealing
stuff because like you said no one goes
and steals spam to resell it on the
market it's three bucks you're not
making a bunch of money on spam
we are now at to the point where people
have to steal food to eat in New York
and they're like look how wacky this is
wacky wacky no no no no no I'm gonna
correct your rice yeah we're at a point
where people have to steal spam that's a
good point to eat that's a good point
because that's not even food yeah good
point
look how much inflation has run up the
price of food yes so so who really just
can't afford to buy the basic necessity
so therefore they're stealing spam you
know I can see why that's happening
especially you know have you been down
the blocks wow okay you've been down the
blocks especially if you've been down
the block especially the other day I was
like ask asking someone a question on
the Block
you speak on TV for a living
have a look at her but honestly no this
is about right for now if this was like
2000 I'd be like you speak on TV for
living what are you doing but now after
everything we've seen we're like yeah
it's about right yes I'm surprised she's
wearing a shirt I mean honestly at this
point but you know the the thing is like
I get that and there are people that are
hungry in this city and it's get ready
for the
Upper West Side no wedding ring spinster
[ __ ] take that is going to be so out
of touch that it's going to blow your
mind and I haven't seen this yet but I
feel I feel it you know you feel it
coming out wages to think that one of
the most you know yeah affluent cities
have people like on their Corner who
can't afford to eat but what we're
finding with some of these thefts it's
not just like they're they're bringing
it home to their family is they go
outside and they resell it immediately
immediately
they are not reselling spam dude there
is a huge huge black market for spam
do you understand that I'm the first one
to tell you whenever I see them going
and stealing like all these things to
ReSound Gucci and all these [ __ ]
Stores
um that I'm the first one to go these
[ __ ] animals who they [ __ ] but
when people are stealing
toothpaste deodorant they just said it
in spam
listen if you're if the items you're
stealing
are items commonly found on the
commissary in jail
then you're probably not living the high
life right like
right all of those items can be
purchased in a prison commissary you can
get spam you can get toothpaste Trevor
just said I buy Street spam all the time
freaks fam hey yo yo yo yo yo yo you got
that spam on yo you got spam
oh yeah and it's so it's not like oh my
goodness I have a cousin in New York
who's literally like a Spam fence let me
ask you a question does he just because
you know you gotta they all have um you
know they don't want to trace the thefts
back to you know get people arrested so
they all go through a fence so I know a
guy who's just all day he's buying
people stolen spam and he's and then
he's selling it across the country where
it can't be traced unbelievable and it's
so it's not like oh my goodness my
family has nothing to eat I'm reselling
it for whatever reason whether it is I'm
stuffing it in those [ __ ] prepaid box
uh those prepaid USPS boxes I got and
people are buying it from me with
ethereum unbelievable I gotta I got this
this take drugs or you know alcohol or
to buy that Gucci suit I don't know
she's insane look I am the first person
to say they do that [ __ ] and it's
horrible we talk about San Francisco but
they are not stealing spams for profits
spam they're probably hungry
and then okay oh an affluence City and
they're actually selling it then how
come one one and there's only one we
haven't asked all of them one New York
food bank said that they went up a
hundred thousand people in the past two
months more than last year at the same
time
during the pandemic
more people are going to food banks
because they can't afford food you're
right they're using it to buy their
golden cars and there's and their space
and their space Jordans
spaceship and they're cooked and they're
Gucci suits
first off if they wanted a Gucci suit
they would just go into Gucci and steal
a suit I feel you're not gonna do
anything I feel like that so many more
steps removed from the process right yo
yo yo how many cans of spam is that soup
and like
um we don't we only accept cash for
credit cards
but this is what I mean like all right
but yo hear me out on this what if I got
like a whole lot of spam
so she thinks that these criminals
are selling spam
to buy Gucci suits Gucci suits damn it
that's a stupid thing she's got like a
[ __ ] dry erase board and she's like
spam question mark Prophet Gucci Gucci
suit so
probably go around depending on which
one and really nice one yeah would
probably go around
20 2600
which give or take per can is three
dollars about 800 cans of okay 800 900
camera well no that's because they have
to sell the cans Less in the stores are
selling them so it's gonna be about a
thousand cans because you know if you're
gonna it's like a gun if you're gonna
buy a hot gun yeah you're gonna pay less
for you yeah you know what I mean so a
thousand cans
the guy in the Thousand spam suits
your questions
foreign
I don't know they're trying to get the
Gucci suits or whatever and in such an
affluent City that people aren't eating
it's like yeah that's because you've
never had dinner south of Midtown like
so you're like you don't even know of
the other New York a man of affluent
money is gonna buy an Armani suit not a
Gucci suit yeah Gucci's more for
Handbags and shoes ma'am you have never
walked through the part of Manhattan
that like gas digital's located in you
know what I mean you've never even been
to that part of New York I've never even
seen a hungry person I don't know she
definitely doesn't go to a part where
gas digital is at because everybody
there looks like Louis J Gomez walking
down the street hey what up doggy Lewis
no I work at the bodega ah [ __ ] man [ __ ]
Louis no no God damn it that's just a
guy that's doing that's just a guy
selling produce
you know that whole neighborhood's so
terrible like then we had to go do that
Bowery electric show oh God we showed up
we're like yeah we'll get there a little
bit hang out as soon as we got there
there's just some guy going I don't do
nothing
oh yeah
nine cops were dragging him into a van
and I'm like this is a nice what a
vibrant neighborhood nobody's rocked you
know what he's locked up for selling
streets fam
I just remembered
and I was like thinking there's like
three cop cars and nine cops here I feel
like he did so that's right I feel like
something led to this
reported by that Gucci suit
but you know
that's a lot of thank you for calling
around somebody at least that's a lot of
spam no I mean it's city of hustle you
know New York City is a city of hustle
so they got to get it how they see it
and I guess she got real Hood yeah it's
the city of hustle y'all you know what
I'm saying that's why sometimes you be
selling Lucy cigarettes so you get
choked to death
bam is really the hot come on that's one
way to get it I know I thought it was
yams but I guess it's spam
socks
what's he doing
I I don't know I I can't first of all
dude those socks are atrocious second of
all your pants are way too short what is
this well if the pants aren't too short
how are you gonna see the socks
I hate them well I get it I hate them
more than any of them right
I say it is annoying when you have the
drugstore and you're trying to get spam
paced yeah toothpaste or something
personal let me guess they're selling
the toothpaste on the street to buy
their Gucci suits
man when was the last time you had to go
stop and get toothpaste really good
point was the last time you somebody
didn't go not even like you're not
getting it post mates exactly that's
what I was gonna say they're gonna get
no post Kroger doesn't come to your
phone Whole Foods doesn't come to your
[ __ ] Upper West Side condo with bags
ready to go